[Musique]
mais que fait
laabuse une histoire de Joël etcormier
illustrée par Nathalie met aux éditions
océan
jeunesse il écume les mers du matin au
et non pas avec une
passoire il scrute l'océan avec sa
longue vue parfois il tombe nez à nez
avec une
baleine il explore l'île Bourbon à la
recherche de la meilleure cachette il
dit que celui qui découvrira son trésor
n'est pas né comme le
poisson il reste des heures dans sa
cabine à inventé des rébut et des
alphabets
secrets il écrit un nouvel article du
code de l'honneur des pirates le dernier
à l'abordage est une poule
mouillée il jure comme un flibustier
parce qu'il a raté une attaque n d'une
barique de Rome troué dans une cale
pleine de
rat il élève des dodos bien doddus dans
les cales de son
navire mais comme ils n'ont pas le pied
marin ils ont le mal de
mer il fête la victoire avec ses hommes
en buvant du Rome et en chantant des
chansons de pirate surtout ne les
apprend
pas il partage le butain de son dernier
pillage avec son
équipe une pièce d'or chacun deux pour
le
capitaine cherche des volontaires pour
s'entraîner au combat au Sabr couteau
entre les
dents et où sont-ils tous
passés il apprend à ses nouveaux
matelots à faire des nœuds il est
imbattable au nœud de chaise et au nœud
plat il adore jouer aux cour de CFAR
avec son équipage le perdant doit
brosser le
pont ceci est un message codé de la buse
pour
toi c'est l'heure de ranger ta chambre
petit
forban il a peur que son kakatoes répète
le secret de son trésor
alors il lui apprend le
japonais finalement il aime mieux un
lémurien de Madagascar comme animal de
compagnie il déguste un délicieux
cacatoes farci au coco et flambé au rum
de
Bourbon c'est la meilleure façon de
cuisiner les
bavards il n'a pas envie d'attraper le
score but la maladie des pirates il
recompte ses dents
tous les jours 31 et
demi il a peur de finir comme le
capitaine Kid couvert de goudron et
pendu enchaîné la nuit il fait des
cauchemars
affreux parfois il fait des drôles de
rêv les bateaux ont des ailes et volent
dans le ciel et lui il est pirate de
l'air il organise un concours du plus
terrifiant drapeau pirate avec son
équipage la tête de mort c'est
complètement
démodée il hésite à se faire percer
l'autre
oreille c'est pas mal pour la vue mais
ça fait pas un peu
fille il demande à son barbier de lui
faire le look de Barbe Noire tresse et
ruban dans la
barbe finalement c une très mauvaise
idée il hisse son pavillon de la
mort
attention à
[Musique]
l'abordage